there is far more leaking out about
hunter biden and the fact that joe biden
absolutely
did know that hunter biden was having
business dealings in china
here is a voicemail this is just
breaking in the last 24-48 hours a
voicemail of joe biden calling hunter to
talk about his business dealings with
china
hey palace dad it's 8 15. um
on wednesday nights because the chance
can be called nothing urgent
i just want to talk to you i thought the
article at least has been on online
that's going to be printed one time it
was good
i think you're clear
and
anyway um
if you get a chance give me a call i
love you
okay so the article that he's referring
to is about
hunter biden's dealings with china okay
that's that's been
verified already we'll get to that in a
sec because even the press secretary is
addre is acknowledging that that is true
now this entire time and you remember
for a year and a half before the
election joe biden was saying hunter had
no business dealings also if he did have
business dealings it had nothing to do
with joe blah blah blah blah here's a
whole bunch of times that joe biden lied
about hunter biden's dealings
period i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
respond to that let's focus on the
problem focus on this man your son did
make a lot of money there some reports
50 to 80 000 a month in a ukrainian
company while you were vice president
i'm not look here's what i'm not gonna
do i'm not gonna and i know you're not
intending to do this play the game to
take the eye off the culprit
there's nothing on his face that was
wrong
so look if you want to talk about
problems
you know let's talk about trump's family
i mean come on here's what i know
i know trump deserves to be investigated
and what i wanted to make a point about
my son's statement speaks for itself he
spoke about it today
my son's statement speaks for itself
what i think is important is we focus on
why it's so important to remove this man
from office
okay so he of course always was throwing
it back on trump and we should
investigate trump's kids for what for
what they're good parents and actual
functioning adults with jobs and
families and things of that nature um
and of course he consistently is lying
there's nothing here that this never
happened blah blah blah blah blah well
now even our black lesbian press
secretary is admitting that yeah
something kind of did happen
why is there a voicemail of the
president
talking to his son about his overseas
business dealings if the president has
said he's never spoken to his son about
his overseas business
well first i'll say that uh
what the president said stands so
if he if that's what the president said
that that is what stands and second
secondly
secondly business dealings and he says i
think you're clear
how is that not him talking to his son
about his overseas business feelings
we're not from this podium i am not
going to talk about alleged materials
from the laptop i will
i'm not
on the voicemail i am not going to talk
about alleged materials on the laptop
it's not happening then that it is not
peter i refer you to uh to his son's
representative
okay so what you need to understand
there is they're admitting it and i'm
telling you they are getting rid of joe
biden soon enough they are he obviously
is not running in 2024 even if it had
nothing to do with this just because of
the cognitive stuff but they are getting
rid of this guy soon enough they used
him as long as they needed him i don't
think they expected him to break down
this quickly i don't think that enough
of this would be that they thought that
so much of this would be exposed so
quickly but they're getting rid of him
she's sort of in on it too right because
she's kind of like yeah yeah there's
some stuff there but i'm not gonna
really talk about it here they're gonna
string him up and congrats to dr jill
biden you have a special place in hell
for what you did to your husband your
basically incapacitated husband
you